it is my pleasure my name is rebecca
kozak
i will be your host for the next two
hours with
this program of ass doc live and i am
here
joined by my co-host jonty mccollier
ruth ellen sanchez and nasima omar
and of course the amazing dr joe wallach
so before we get started we got to just
read this wonderful little disclaimer
it helps you know that the content of
this program is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician
it is for nutritional education only
the fda requires us to let you know that
our products are not
meant to treat prevent diagnose or cure
any diseases
but when you give the body what it needs
your body can do some amazing
things and the testimonials that you
will hear
on this program are testimonials using
the products that dr
wallick has recommended for the
individual
which he'll be recommending for you as
well so
be an empowered individual you don't
have to rely on a system that is
managing
health and keeping you sick and on
pharmaceuticals
we have the father the co-father
of epigenetics where he has
proven through research and through
clinical putting his research to action
that there are no genetic diseases
you've got genetic
you've got not genetic you've got
nutritional deficiencies
starting from the womb and without
further ado
it again is my honor to be able to
provide this resource
to you and this amazing individual
dr joel wallach dr wallach
good morning rebecca good morning team
thank you
okay um we have some good news and some
sad news this morning
uh let's go with the sad news first
india
reported their highest rate of new
infections in one day 314
835 and
they're running about 200
000 infections per day and they hit that
spike
in the last 24 hours at 314 835.
the biggest spike they've had is 9
million new cases in one day
remember they're the second largest
population on earth so 1.4 billion
people second only to the chinese
and they had the greatest
rate of death the highest rate of death
during the spanish flu in 1918
where they had 20 million people die in
six months
they had 110 million people infected in
that same six months
and um indians are very interesting
they have a split population they have
29 states i spent a lot of time on the
un and the world health organization
websites and stuff figuring this out
you have 29 states and seven territories
in our
other nine states are totally different
than the southern 20 states and seven
territories now they're all
a homogenous people they're all the same
people okay they don't have 16 different
races and
people from different origins and things
are all the same so that's
helpful but the northern
nine states they live on wheat by ryan
oates and they have
95 percent of the deaths and 86 percent
of the infections
the southern 20 states in seven
territories they live on
maize corn rice sweet potatoes uh beans
squash and algae
and they only have five percent of the
deaths and only 14 percent of the
infections
okay what's the difference well that
gluten from the northern states kills
their intestines they don't get the
algae
so they're not getting any mineral
supplementation for their bone marrows
to make
white blood cells red blood cells
platelets and antibodies
and so uh even since uh 1918
the northern nine states of india have
been
hit many times harder than the southern
20 states and seven territories
but there is a reason for that is their
diet it's their diet
now the
good news is we know what's going on
we know in fact let me give you our
figures for the usa this is as of this
morning
we have 32 million 671
025 infections 32 million 671
025 infections as of this morning
in india they have um
remember they have 1.4 billion people
we're one-fifth of their population
they have 16 million infections
and 184 000 dead they have half the
infections we have
and about one third of the deaths we
have
okay and so that's because we
primarily live on gluten wheat around
oats oatmeal the breakfast
champions wheaties cream of wheat
pancakes waffles bread
bread bread spaghetti um
let's see here pizza crusts that are
made from wheat
bagels matzahs everything we eat
is wheat everything we drink and when
you look at michigan which has the
highest rate
of daily infections a little state in
the midwest
they have you know they average between
five and a half and six
thousand and five point five and 6 000
new infections every day what is going
on there
well that's because they have the
highest rate of home
micro breweries they're all making um
beer and drinking their beer made from
wheat
okay so that's i figured that out so we
got to change all this
okay now remember there's another piece
here we're not only responsible for
ourselves
and our neighbors but we're also
responsible for any future babies we
have
and during wars and during pandemics
there's always
a spike in babies being born with birth
defects because everybody eats crazy
drinks and
doesn't supplement and so forth so i
urge everybody to remember
uh as rebecca said
myself along with bruce lipton were
considered the fathers
of this of the science of epigenetics i
have a great best-selling book
epigenetics the death of the junk jersey
transmission
it goes along with two cds by the same
title epigenetics the death
the genetic theory of disease
transmission and
it goes into all the birth defects okay
with the exception
of some infections like the pandemic and
other infections early in pregnancy
where the embryo is damaged by the virus
and also maybe some poisons where people
are drinking during pregnancy and they
get you know
um feel alcohol syndrome and that kind
of stuff the exception of those things
all birth defects are caused by
nutritional deficiencies in the first 90
days of pregnancy
prenatal vitamins say you're supposed to
take them before pregnancy pre-pregnancy
prenatal
okay and most women do not take prenatal
vitamins until they've missed two
periods and they go to the
drugstore and they get one of those home
tests and they pee on it and sure enough
they're pregnant well
they've been doing all the bad stuff for
the first two months of pregnancy and
they have a high probability of having a
baby
with a problem okay well it gets worse
during wars and pandemics and stuff like
that because people are just
doing crazy things and not thinking
about tomorrow so i want you to remember
if you're in the childbearing years and
you're sexually active even if you're
not sexually active in your childbearing
years
you know after friday night on alcohol
and everything and you think the world
is coming to an end tomorrow anything
can happen
on friday night and so you need to be
getting rid of the bad food saying
maximize absorption no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat product oats
no sugar okay all that's got to go
and then um you need to take the 90
essential nutrients
remember all birth defects are caused by
nutritional deficiencies
and we're talking about you know some
really weird stuff here
let's look at some of these birth
defects
down syndrome is caused by deficiency
early in pregnancy i've been able to
reverse them
before the end of the third month of
pregnancy by giving them other
heavy-duty vitamins and metals
and they were diagnosed with the three
screen tests and the ultrasound i mean
i've seen the ultrasounds we're talking
about lauren knievel
evel knievel you know the daredevil's
niece and law
and she had a very severely affected
embryo
down syndrome and she sent her overnight
they held their brain and heart pack
this is like uh
25 years ago and she started taking it
dutifully and staying away from all the
bad stuff
and the baby noah knievel was born
perfectly normal
freaked everybody out including the
doctors because they they're looking at
those
three screen tests and the ultrasound
they say this can't be maybe we got it
wrong let's
check this kid again is this dna is this
you're really your kid
and so forth because they couldn't
believe it wasn't a down syndrome baby
and then we're talking about sickle cell
anemia that's not a genetic
thing sickle cell anemia occurs in
everybody it's not just in black folks
but in white folks and asians and
latinos they call it
what what
you get tell me doc cause i just like
i knew that in my brain and i went to
say it i'm like
no that's not right
okay i'll give it to you in a second
okay
um it's caused by a nutritional
deficiency early in pregnancy
okay and the the um
babies are born with sickle cells but
they can't call it sickle cells because
they're not black it's supposed to be a
genetic disease black folks
but it's a nutritional deficiency early
in pregnancy okay
and they um
they don't pass it on you can get two
people with the sickle cell anemia
whether they're white or black
or red or yellow doesn't matter and
they can have 10 babies and none of them
will have sickle cell anemia if the
mother's taking the 90 cents of
nutrients before pregnancy starts
okay because it's um
it's not a genetic disease okay the same
thing is true
with uh let's see here let's look at um
uh oh let's look at gender issues
okay everybody freaks out over this
gender stuff
and they're talking about um people who
are
uh bi bisexual who are asexual
uh who who are um transgender
and all that kind of stuff and everybody
wants to say this is my
choice no they're kind of driven that
way because it's an under
caused by an underdevelopment of the
hypothalamus which is the part of the
brain that tells you
who to chase for sex it doesn't matter
what equipment you have between your
legs
whether you're a boy or girl or you have
both or whatever it doesn't matter
you're going to chase who your brain
tells you to chase and
if your hypothalamus is underdeveloped
you get a problem
just like cerebral palsy cerebral palsy
doctors oh yeah you have an autoimmune
disease your baby's born
you know but you know no ability to walk
properly and everything like that
cerebral palsy
but what happened was the baby didn't
get enough nutrition when the brain was
developing
and it was a cerebellum which controls
your balance and
your ability to exercise and move and
everything was underdeveloped
and see here i'm having a
noise here in the background okay so
anyway
um all these things are totally 100
percent preventable
so they got to take the 90th century
nutrition stay away from the bad foods
and they will avoid having babies nine
months from now or a year from now
with all these terrible diseases just
remember
there's always a spike during wars and
pandemics and all this kind of stuff
um and so i urge you
to really really take your 90th century
nutrients really really really stay away
from the bad stuff
and we will come out of this in good
shape
so um with that
then i also want people to take care of
themselves they need to take
our hand sanitizer it comes these little
two ounce bottles i have a little cart
by the door
which all the teenagers just left okay
through the door um and so um
i put a we have the pint pump bottles
i put that on the cart i take these
little two ounce things with me in my
pocket or my briefcase
and uh her hand sanitizer i also have
one of our bottles of colloidal silver
i take two droppers full of this um
a half hour before each meal and a half
hour before bedtime we've been doing
that for 25 years rebecca
the colloidal silver kills every virus
and bug and fungus and bacteria you can
think of i mean we're talking about hiv
aids we're talking about the spanish flu
we're talking about
uh covet 2 covet 19 we're talking about
polio we're talking about all these
diseases okay syphilis
this kills them all okay and so why not
take it as a preventative so i've been
doing it as a preventative for 25 years
and so it just really works for me
because i deal with so many people
and who knows what they got what they
don't got and right so
i just take that and then also um
for energy uh during the day i take our
rebound or sports drink
with a hundred nutrients in it you know
we have red bull and gatorade which has
a couple of nutrients and mostly sugar
and caffeine
this has a hundred nutrients in it and
it has the nutrition in it it has a
special nutrients in there
to prevent that heart death that kills
these young athletes now there was just
a 19 year old
basketball player who had just signed an
nba contract after he graduated college
he was 19 years
old he signs the contract he's going
home and he dies of this heart attack
i guarantee you he was drinking one of
these energy drinks with no nutrition in
it
he wasn't drinking our rebound okay what
a terrible tragic story
okay i'm sure his family is like what
this great young athlete how could he
die of a heart attack
well he died of a heart attack because
this is what's called hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease and sudden
heart death in young athletes
right now in america this year so far
we're not even halfway through the year
we've already got 500 000 young people
under the age of 30 who've died of
hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart attack
dr milan and i did 1700 autopsies on
kids
in china in heilongjiang province
keyshawn university
in 1988 because we knew that that
nutritional deficiency caused by
nutritional deficiency
caused these other diseases so we found
in 1 700 we found
35 percent had cystic fibrosis supposed
to the classic genetic
genetically transmitted birth defect and
then 100 had mustard history
and 200 of them under the age of 1 years
of age would have been diagnosed with
sediment death syndrome here in the
states
so we got it all written up and
published in three languages
in 1990 the english version is the
biology of trace element research 1990
please get that and read it
and you will be flabbergasted all these
birthday effects are preventable
we gave that to jerry lewis in 2011
after we kept treating
literally hundreds of people um in
utah and idaho with muscular speed they
have one of the highest rates in of
muscular usa
that they had and so we figured out we
started giving them these nutrients and
even ones that are 31 years old and they
were born with muscle history and
they're 31 years old and really ready to
die we give them our stuff and it all
goes away
okay because it's a nutritional
deficiency it's not a genetically
transmitted birth effect
we'll make a long story short um
a year and a half after uh april 16 2013
when we won a federal case with that
study one thousand seven
hundred autopsies on these kids under
the age of ten
they couldn't resist one thousand seven
hundred autopsy data
so the federal judges ruled that all the
baby farmers infamous similac and all
the rest of them had to put this one
nutrient in the baby farmers which they
did
a year and a half later okay we're
talking september 13
2014 the big newspaper in charlotte
north carolina the charlotte observer
came out and said front page like third
world war i mean we're talking about big
bold letter headlines
we don't know why but sentiment down
syndrome has vanished in the state of
north carolina
three months later st louis post
dispatch all the newspapers in missouri
came out so we don't know why but
sentiment death syndrome has vanished in
the state of missouri
then three months later every newspaper
in the world came out and said we don't
know why but the diagnosis of suddenly
death syndrome
um diagnosis has dropped dramatically by
85 to 95
all over the world and the rate of death
from sediment death syndrome went from
one and three hundred to one in three
thousand
okay because they put that nutrient in
there
now here we come
this is very simple this is very simple
this is not difficult why do we not have
health insurance for farm animals we
don't need it because we give them
vitamins and minerals
okay uh farmers would not pay a
veterinarian to counter every day and
treat their
hogs and their beef animals their sheep
and their chickens their turkeys their
pigs and so forth
they would just kill them and eat them
okay
they would not be giving long-term
maintenance and management treatments
well
health insurance was one of the biggest
negatives for human health in america
because it gives doctors permission to
manage your disease
and charge your insurance over and over
and over and over and milk you like a
milk machine
like a milk cow because they don't feel
guilty because it's not coming out of
your pocket insurance is paying
but you're still suffering okay when you
get rid of the disease in 30 days type 2
diabetes is not a genetic disease you
get rid of it in 30 to 60 days it's a
simple nutritional deficiency i don't
care if you've had it for 30 years
okay so wake up
get with you know get with us and um
we'll walk you through this this is not
difficult okay over to you rebecca
no it's not difficult not difficult at
all
and dr wallick i've actually experienced
not my personal self but somebody i know
that was
told that they were going to have a down
syndrome baby and we got them on a
nutritional program
and she's beautiful bouncing little girl
with absolutely
no signs evidence nothing
well if i may just one minute here let
me interrupt you there
we have a young couple who were down
syndrome babies
and you know their parents they didn't
know each other
but they gave their kids our products
from the ten they're like eight years
old they got married
i'll see it's ben and wendy erdmann
okay from dallas texas you've probably
heard of them
and they um he got a job he went to
school at the
texas a m got a degree in engineering
and they had him teaching
electrical engineering at texas a m
he just retired uh i don't know six
months ago after 20 years of teaching
um here's a down syndrome couple they're
beautiful
and when you look at them you're really
hard-pressed to tell their down syndrome
because they've been on our products for
like
you know 40 years and so
um even even late you can still do
benefit for people with down syndrome by
getting on the products and getting off
the bad foods
well and so let's we're kind of moving
away from downs on this one but
i i have a business builder that i'm
working with
and she has a son she put her son on the
products four years ago
and he was high functioning autistic but
could not function in a classroom
and now dr wallach he's taking full load
classes
out of college and doing fabulously
isn't that beautiful it's wonderful i
mean she's
she was like she knew there was
something out there
and she kept searching and searching and
when she
heard you on the radio she had some hope
she gave us a call i was fortunate to be
um you know the one that took the call
and and i know ruth ellen has worked
with her as well
and it's just been something that
it's life-changing for their whole
family
no there you go incredible absolutely
incredible
i love it i love stories like that and
we hear them
all the time yeah when we get them by
the thousands every day okay remember
we're in 50 countries
we may be more than that now i have to
check but you know as of
a year ago we're in 50 countries i think
we're probably closer to 55 57 countries
now so i'll have to get the data
but um we're all over the world we see
two million people a day
i want you to remember rebecca
that in the old testament there were 83
miracles
okay check that out in the new testament
there's 80 miracles
we create two million miracles every day
because the information we have an army
of people uh back in the bible days they
didn't have electronics they didn't have
telephones they didn't have emails and
all kinds of stuff
you know he had the angels and the
apostles walking from one village to the
next and talking to three people
and i'm sure there were more miracles
but they didn't get recorded because
everything was so remote and there's no
way to record it and pass it around the
world overnight
but now we get a miracle like we get
somebody who hadn't urinated for 10
years
and we get them on our program and in
two weeks time they're urinating and
they get them off the dialysis in a
couple of weeks
and they've been on dialysis for 25
years
okay and so these are the sort of
miracles we do every day
and uh and of course we put it on the
internet and so forth
bam the world knows about it so we're
seeing two million
miracles a day and so that's why we're
working hard on a on a book
uh coming out actually i have two books
coming out
and uh one of them is is is so crazy
it's scary
okay because it goes back it goes back
to the beginning
when you know in in genesis
in the old testament it says um in the
beginning
god created the heavens and the earth
but it doesn't say did it take him five
minutes 15 minutes a half hour three
days
six weeks a million years you know we
don't it doesn't say and then it goes
into the rest of the story
and so i went back and finally found out
you know when the universe was created
and so we got that that's all gonna be
in the beginning of this book and we're
going to give god all the credit
but we're going to fill in that you know
he jumped from
or whoever wrote the bible jumped from
god created the heavens and the earth
which is true but
then how long did it take before the
garden of eden came along
well i have all the dates and everything
because they've dated the garden of eden
they've dated when
adam was created and so forth so this
goes along with all the dates of
everything else i know
and it's all going to be put in the
proper order
it's going to be a freaky freaky
book oh dr wallick it definitely sounds
like it's going to be an interesting
and much a must read
book yeah so speaking of your books dr
wallach i just want to let everybody
know that you can find dr wallach's most
popular books
on our website at askdoclive.com
so you can go to the website find that
there and also
all of the products that dr wallach is
going to be mentioning today
in the protocol says we're getting to
all these hands this is absolutely
fabulous
are on that website as well under
our store plus the replay of this
program so again
if somebody sent you here to watch this
program get back with them
but if not you can feel free to use that
store
to get the products that you need as
well now if you have specific questions
that you would like to have
answers to we do have a team of
certified holistic health coaches
that are available to answer your
questions
via email on that website
there's a contact us you can send us an
email
and we will have somebody get in touch
with you
for those of you again who were not sent
here by somebody specific we also have a
call team that will be standing by
at eight five five nine four nine
seven two three four we do have a team
that is there
waiting to take your call so dr wallach
we have
a ton of hands up already so
let's go ahead and get started
let's go with judy who has her hand out
judy
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach
hello judy one more time
okay she's not getting unmuted so let's
go ahead and move to the next ten and
that is mary hello mary i know you're
waiting
go ahead and unmute yourself mary
oh it's not you doc hold on oh judy's
unmuted let's go to judy real quick
okay hi i'm i'm judy i am 64.
i have really bad osteoporosis and
i'm 110 pounds okay
uh judy do you have any other issues do
you have anything like um
uh high blood pressure diabetes uh
thyroid issues anything like that
no i'm really good i'm really good with
that stuff okay do you have any ringing
in the ears any tonight is ringing the
ears or balance problems
uh balance i'm i'm going blind and i'm
almost blind
so i think the balance might go with
that possibly okay
well um you have osteoporosis of the
skull
you have what's called o-n-a optic nerve
atrophy and i've won so many bets i've
won so many bottles of wine
and um big dinners at
ruth chris's steakhouse because doctors
have lost bets with me
i take people who are blind six eight
ten twelve years
uh they think it's macular degeneration
which is a kind of
degenerative disease of the lining of
the eye
of the retina in the eye but really
what's happening is when you have
osteoporosis of the skull
the tunnels that the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves come through and that the
the spinal cord goes through get filled
up and they're like 50
of the size they're supposed to be and
they squeeze the nerves when you have
ona optic nerve atrophy
the skull is squeezing the optic nerve
slowly slowly squeezing the optic nerve
and slowly you slowly use your lose your
vision
okay and um it also squeezes the artery
going
to the back of the eye it also squeezes
the veins coming back from the eyes all
kinds of weird things can happen there's
like
10 different diseases you can get when
you have osteoporosis of the skull
that affect the optic nerve so you have
osteoporosis call that causes the
dizziness
the balance problems also the gradual
blindness
uh the doctors always get it wrong i
will say that again they always get
wrong because when they look in the eye
they don't see a cataract they don't see
um they don't they test the pressure and
there's no pressure in there so they
don't have glaucoma so they just blame
it on
macular degeneration and they don't know
what else to do but it's actually ona
i want you to get a hold of the book
called it's all in your head goes into
the 25 different diseases you get when
you have osteoporosis the skull
how come it is medical doctors don't
tell people about osteoporosis in the
skull
it's not just osteoporosis in your leg
bones your pelvis and your vertebrae
you also get osteoporosis there's 25
different diseases you get to
and you go to all these specialists and
they milk your insurance policy
so i want you to get a hold of that book
it's all in your head and then i want
you to get rid of all the bad foods you
can maximize absorption absolutely no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat probably i know no
sugar
okay then i want you to take it 110
pounds
i want you to take one healthy brain and
heart pack per month but i also want you
to get another bottle of our selenium
not from all greens but our selenium
it has five cofactors in there you need
and so i want you to take three of those
twice a day because one comes with the
health brain heart pack
then i want you to get one bottle of
msm's you can take three of those twice
a day and they will support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone breaks
your bone itself
which includes not only the bone and the
skull but also the bone marrow which
produces your
white blood cells and your antibodies
your red blood cells and platelets which
is your immune system and this pandemic
time that's very important
okay i also want you to take our vitamin
d3 take three of those twice a day
as two bowels a month it'll help you
absorb the minerals particularly calcium
and put that
into the proper places in all your bones
and then i want you to also
take our glucogel take
110 pounds i go ahead and take uh three
or four or five of those twice a day
there's two bowels a month of our
glucogel
i also want you to get our fucoid z
which supports your immune system
but also it uh supports your bone marrow
cavity the the nine
algaes and and seaweeds that are in
the fucoid z um actually
support your bone marrow which is very
important when you have an osteoporosis
as a bone marrow cavity fills up with
scar tissue and fat okay
um is called bone marrow
dysplasia okay and that's why
people get prescriptions of iron and b12
pills and that don't work because they
they're
ville or dead because they're eating
gluten so they come in once a month to
get shots of b12 and r
people don't like that and then doctors
want to do a bone marrow transplant
which is
no it doesn't hurt the patient
financially because insurance will pay
the hundred thousand dollars
okay but there's risk and of course
that's not the answer to the problem
so do these things call us every two
weeks let us know what's going on
because you're going to get your vision
back
oh wow okay and so
you bet and also you're going to
increase your immune system
so you can fend off you know the bad
guys okay
thank you very much i appreciate it okay
we look forward to hearing from you judy
god bless you
thank you awesome thank you judy and
again you can find the replay of what dr
wallach recommended for you at
askdoclive.com
let's move on to mary mary
go ahead and unmute yourself again you
are on live with dr wallach
hi mary hi there did it
work you're on
um first of all i got to say i want to
thank you
for paying for the shipping for my
products
i get uh i get them all the time you
know
yeah you're on auto ship so i pay the
shipping yeah yep
i appreciate it and uh i probably don't
need to
tell you anything because the lady
before me
was what i needed except i weigh more
than her
how much you weigh i weigh 130
and i'm five foot tall and i'm 88.
okay now i know you have certain
problems because you have gray hair do
you have any varicose veins your legs
oh yes well varicose veins and gray hair
caused by the same nutritional
deficiency
gray hair is not due to age it's a
nutritious i've seen 12 year old kids
like michael jackson you know the famous
black singer
uh he he had white hair had vitiligo
over his whole body he lost his skin
pigment
he died of 51 of a ruptured eric
aneurysm which is also caused by the
same deficiency so
i need to make sure i want you to at
least take one healthy brain and heart
pack per month at 130 pounds
i want you get an extra bottle of our
selenium with all the cofactors in there
and your hair color will come back and
the varicose veins will go away
okay because these are caused by
nutritional deficiencies not by aging
okay and um then
let's see here do you have any skin
problems any eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis
no okay um
all right so you don't have any other
issues so let's go
may i ask you i don't like to talk
bad about our products but um i
cannot take the ultimate efa it
it i had a reaction to it okay now is
that the dark ones are the clear ones
uh the dark ones okay
okay the ultimate classic yes okay
you're talking about the intelligence
okay ultimate here phase okay yeah yeah
yeah okay
and because you're talking about the
dark ones well these this is the
essential fatty acids from seeds
the efa pluses they're in the amber
clear ones are you able to take those
i think so yes uh-huh okay okay good
well they come from
they come from fish oil vegetable ones i
went to the
vegetable one yeah okay okay
yeah well we have to do two of them
you're happy it doesn't matter which one
you get them for
you know we just we have two different
sources for just that
sort of uh information so no that's why
we have
the source from fish and we have the
source from seeds so you choose yours
i take three of each of them twice a day
okay well thank you so much mary keep us
informed but i want to see you
every couple of weeks because i want
people to see that you're you know
within six months you're going to have i
don't know what your original hair color
was blonde red black
brown wood black okay let's keep looking
for
for black hair okay well i'm already
getting it so
yeah okay thank you very much doc
bye bye bye bye all right awesome
awesome well dr welling people say you
have too many products but this is
exactly why
we have the products that we have so
that things can be tailored directly
and specifically for the individual so
that's something i
love about us yeah well we have products
for over 600 different diseases we have
5 000
products okay now
probably i would say a good couple
hundred of them
are skin care and beauty products and
you know laundry detergent and stuff
like that
but other than those that couple hundred
you know the rest of our all nutrition
okay so we have four thousand about 850
nutritional products
and remember there's 600 different
diseases we deal with
and so you have to have all this stuff
in various combinations and
and strengths
and because you have babies you know
they need liquids
okay like kids toddy and then you have
athletes you know they want the big
hammer of course we have the plague
right now so we have to have the big
hammer
and plague was the word they used for
pandemics back in the bible days
and um why they changed it to pandemic i
don't know
a pandemic is a plague a plague is a
pandemic
it's kind of funny i guess pandemic is
just not as
ugly of a sounding word as plague
i don't know but it's just not it's not
good and the nice thing about it though
folks is
we can protect ourselves we may get
something that is part of the plague but
we can fight we can overcome
and we can come out stronger and more
vibrant than we were when going into it
so keep that in mind we are empowered
we do not have to be a victim to
anything
now dr wallach my first question um that
was sent to me this week
she said your skin is so pretty did you
ever have skin
issues and yes i did um
i had very dry skin i had rosacea
i had my my feet were
cracking my fingers were cracking all
around my fingernails
um my skin well rosacea so it was always
red
and that was the first time i saw you dr
wallach
you had mentioned i had stood up and
started telling you some of the problems
that i was having
he says you have a gluten intolerance
and
one of the first things i said was okay
and you said i can tell because the
color because your skin is so red and
you've got rosacea
and i said well i've got a sunburn i'm
always sunburned he said
you said no you have a gluten
intolerance
you have rosacea
i kept gluten out dr wallick and
my skin you can tell right now yeah i
haven't been sunburned in a long time
well your skin is beautiful
her she goes on and she says um i was
diagnosed with rosacea and high blood
pressure
my doctor said my rosacea will not go
away
unless i use this antibiotic cream
and i refuse but my skin gets really red
and that seems to be getting worse i
have removed gluten from my diet
and i need to know what nutritional
products can i
take to help get rid of
the rosacea and get rid of
high blood pressure okay well here here
what we need to do
she needs to get rid of gluten but also
she needs she cannot be cooking for
anybody else
you know cooking pancakes and spaghetti
and waffles and things for other people
she cannot work in a bakery she cannot
work as
a waitress any of those kind of things
where gluten is involved in delivering
bread to people's tables and all that
kind of stuff
she i mean she's got to be her
environment everybody who comes to her
house if they eat gluten she they got a
strip in the front yard and she's got to
hose them down before she lets them in
the house
okay no gluten then uh per 100 pounds of
body weight
she needs to take one healthy brain
heart pack per month the big hammer in
the toolbox because
she's been on the gluten issue for a
long time
and so she's got a lot of problems going
on here and she could just
be walking down the street and drop dead
from a ruptured aneurysm so she really
needs to get on this
then a one healthy brain and heart pack
for 100 pounds of body weight
if she weighs less than 130 pounds i
want to get another bottle of our
selenium so you can take three of those
twice a day because one bottle comes
with
the um uh healthy brain and heart pack
yeah okay and uh so
her skin will get better the rosacea
goes away
this is a classic nutritional deficiency
disease caused by deficiency of a big
clumsy molecule
and it's one of the first things that
people see when they get
a long-term gluten issues because they
can't absorb that nutrient
and so they always see like psoriatic
arthritis they get psoriasis they get
rosacea
they get celiac disease
in their intestines all that kind of
stuff from gluten
okay and because they then have all this
damage their intestines
they can't absorb other nutrients and so
they wind up having
uh immune deficiency they say oh you
have an autoimmune deficiency
okay you have lupus which is autoimmune
disease your body's attacking itself no
and they have this advertisement on tv i
don't know if you've ever seen it they
show this big
stream of eosinophils you know the white
blood cells that deal with
inflammatory things and allergies and so
they get this big stream of eosinophils
going into
this intestine they say you have celiac
disease and the eosinophils are
destroying your intestines
no they're in the intestines because
they're trying to relieve the
inflammation
because of gluten they've missed it by a
thousand miles and let them get on tv
with this crazy
180 degree wrong information
and i don't know who to choke first okay
that's a tv advertisement i see four
times a day now
on tv uh for this drug that
it's actually a cortisone or prednisone
or something like that says
now one of the side effects of these
this drug is you get cancer and you get
other diseases which will kill you
but you won't die from celiac disease
why would you take it why would you take
a drug where the side effect is death
that doesn't sound good to me no it
doesn't
and since we're talking about that folks
i really
encourage you to read that insert that
comes with your pharmaceuticals
so your doctor is not going to tell you
the bad stuff it's just the good stuff
that he's been told
but read that insert it blows me
away the people that we have come on and
they have
all of these joint pains and body pains
and blood pressure
issues and they're on a pharmaceutical
where those are the first things that
are the side effects
it's like okay let's let's look pick
another approach
that's not going to give you the side
effects at least not negative side
effects i love my side effects for
dr wallach i mean i can run up and down
stairs and i can go outside
not worry about you know anything
falling i used to fall up and down
stairs
because my knees were so bad and my
migraines were so bad
so i love the side effects of not having
any of those
negative health issues it's fabulous
yeah i can use that extra time to deal
with life
i can enjoy life dr wallick
yeah not deal with it i can enjoy it and
i do i very much do enjoy
life let's go to our next hand
up and it's my buddy lance
lance go ahead and unmute yourself you
are on live with dr wallach
hi good morning good morning
uh thank you i want to thank you so much
for all the work you do
uh i think it's pretty amazing um
this country spends a ridiculous amount
of money
on health care and so
i think the work you do is uh just
amazing well you're very kind
thank you um but i have a client
who uh her name is brenda now she's been
diagnosed with lupus and uh
she's 235 pounds five foot six
70 years old now
she has her only symptoms are
basically she gets a sharp pain in the
back of her neck
and her left foot is swollen um
and now does she have that rosacea that
that you know
red mask on her face kind of thing
rosacea on her face
no her skin is good
she doesn't have any skin issues
but and she has no tendinitis and
her eyesight is fairly good and
but she does have gray hair and spider
veins
and swelling in her left foot
okay does she have any bowel problems
any constipation diarrhea celiac disease
irritable bowel syndrome
uh only bloating
okay yeah okay so she never complains
about irregular heart rate or anything
like that
uh yes uh she does have an irregular
heartbeat
okay so she's got a afib atrial
fibrillation
okay that's she's got osteoporosis to
the skull
okay okay so she's getting those kind of
nerves squeezed okay so that'll make
affect all kinds of things
tinnitus ringing in the ears balance
issues
um she began to slowly lose her vision
as the optic nerve gets squeezed get on
a optic nerve atrophy because the skull
is squeezing that
um ringing in the ears balance problems
irregular heart rate
bloating and stomach issues is called
gastroparesis is caused by the
skull squeezing the 10th cranial nerve
that's that same nerve that actually
causes the irregular heart rate
and every once while there's a branch of
that 10th trail nerve called the
recurrent nerve when that gets squeezed
when that branch gets squeezed you get
hiccups and people say i don't know why
i just get hiccups for 10 15 minutes two
or three times a day
and so that's because that 10th cranial
nerve is being squeezed okay so here we
go
now the doctor uh excuse me dr wallach
but
the doctors are telling them that she
has real low white blood count
yeah because she has her bone marrow is
dead i see
okay right that makes sense
yeah okay she got osteoporosis her
her bone marrow cavity she has dysplasia
okay it's all scar tissue and fat and
she's not making many white blood cells
okay and uh you know that's why they
think she's got an autoimmune disease
and all that stuff no she's got
osteoporosis
and wherever that osteoporosis goes
there will be
a dramatic effect which she's showing
okay she got atrial fibrillation she's
got a regular heart rate and doctors
think she's got a heart problem no it's
her skull is squeezing the temps brain
on her she's got bloating
does she have ulcers or that kind of
stuff no uh she's got gastroparesis
again that's caused by squeezing the
tenth cranial nerve and then
um she's got varicose veins in white
here this is all caused by deficiency of
a single nutrient
which causes breakdown of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
artery walls vein walls and so
when they're done when there's so many
things going on there and the doctors
don't know what to call it they say oh
you have an autoimmune disease you have
lupus blah blah blah blah well here we
go
five foot six i want to see a lady we
may weigh 140 pounds so she needs to
lose about
90 to 100 pounds i wanted to start off
with one of her
three meals a day just start off with
one meal a day
of our keto caramel meal it could be the
bar or the shake just start out one meal
a day
and after a month or so and she's
comfortable with how that works she can
try
say two or three or four days a week not
all week but two or three or four days a
week go for two meals a day
okay the rest of her meals she needs to
eat like an asian
corn maize rice sweet potatoes
bean squash
excuse me and seaweed which we'll get to
in a minute
then i want her to take two healthy
painted heart patch per month
two healthy brain and heart peppermint
that's our biggest hammer in the toolbox
i wanted to take
uh two full doses twice a day the
healthy brain hard pack of everything in
that box
and then i wanted her to also get two
bottles a month over msm so you can take
three with each meal
and they're designed to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself
and at various different rates of speed
all of her problems will go away okay
she also needs our vitamin d3 she can
take three of those twice a day that's
two bowels a month
she could take um our um
let's see here collagen or glucagon i
wanted to take five of those twice today
is two vowels a month
i also want her to take either our um
pro joint fx at noon time take through
those capsules then or she could take
our
collagen peptides at noon time one or
the other and then i also wanted her to
take three of our
fucoid z capsules three times a day
that's our algae
our main algae product has nine
different uh seaweeds and algaes in it
as all the trace minerals from the ocean
and if she wants
i do this i also take the ocean's gold
so i take three of each twice a day
and gives you all these weird trace
minerals from the ocean it makes your
bone marrow happy so you can make white
blood cells
okay again even if you only have a
modest amount of bone marrow
left but the bone marrow will regrow and
repopulate
as long as she's getting off of the
wheat butter i know so she can absorb
the nutrients
and it's an amazing miracle so again
i see probably two million miracles a
day throughout the world
and this is just an expression of what
people
used to see 2 000 years ago during bible
days they're on a bad diet
one of these um angels or
are one of these followers you know
moses or jesus or
whoever they were following uh they'd
say well eat this way
and all of these um religions came up
with diets okay which helped a lot of
people you think about that
okay this religion has this diet this
religion has this diet this religion has
this diet
and even the people in california the
seventh-day adventists they have their
diet right
and so when you have all these various
religious groups
uh they usually start because they have
a large number of people in their
community
who have certain problems or
combinations of problems
and they find out a diet that works and
they start spreading that diet
and they create a religion it's kind of
crazy but you see the same scenario over
and over and over and over i don't know
how many
there's i think 12 major religions
around the world and every one of them
has a different diet
so there you go
okay great thank you so much appreciate
that we'll give us
give us an update every couple of weeks
because she's going to show
benefit very quickly if she does
everything we say
okay i certainly will okay thank you sir
okay thank you bye-bye have a great day
wonderful
thank you so much lots of great
information shared there's
there folks so i hope you're paying
attention
now dr wallach i have a question that
has come in
that has to do with scar tissue this
individual was in a
car accident years ago and they thought
that they had
a food blockage and it turned out to be
scar tissue that had built up in the
intestines from the accident
what can be done to help them with that
okay well they can blame it on the
accident but maybe it's gluten
maybe i remember in the old days
everybody knew that the plagues were due
to evil spirits
they knew it
[Laughter]
so what this person needs to do is get
rid of all the bad foods you know
do the things you can do no fr dried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens that we are around notes no
wheat by rhinos no wheat bar ryan oats
there are no such things as gluten free
oats the gluten in oats is called
gliadin
and a copper jacketed bullet will kill
you just as well as a
as a just a lead bullet okay so don't
think you can eat gluten-free oats
because there is no such thing there are
no such thing as gluten-free oats
no sugar and then one healthy brain and
heart pack for 100 pounds of body
weight i also wanted to take the fucoid
z
anti-inflammatory support the immune
system support the bone marrow cavity
okay and
support repair okay so take three of
those
fucoid z capsules um
twice a day two vowels a month and i
would also
take our digestive enzymes or ultimate
enzymes go ahead and take two or three
of those say
ten 15 minutes for each meal a couple
ounces of water
and then you know contact us email us or
call us every couple of weeks and let us
know what goes on
because i think even if these scar
tissue in the intestines is due to an
accident i think getting on a
gluten-free diet and taking the nine
cents of nutrients is going to give this
individual benefit
all right thank you so much dr wallach
let's go to the next hand
up and we have abus
go ahead and unmute yourself
i'm sure was that abba it's abbas
yeah hi how are you okay how can we help
you
uh actually i'm 128
pound five foot six sixty four and a
half to be exact
uh i'm on like i have my thyroid problem
like 10 years ago
okay okay stop stop stop stop where are
you from where are you from
i'm from toronto you're a canadian
yeah how come you have an accent yeah
because i'm originally from
middle east from baghdad iraq well cool
that's what i was asking oh i'm sorry
yeah yeah
i thought okay yeah okay so
i have white hair do you have any
varicose veins in your legs
no okay spider veins in your legs
no do you have bowel problems
constipation diarrhea
no okay do you have uh how about
pressure diabetes
uh it's good like uh i start my diet
like years ago
and it's good the only thing i have my
thyroxine my thyroid so i have 13.00
milligram and six months ago i had my
heart beat something so i
my physician transferred me to the
specialist to cardiologist
she put me two days on halter and eco
and she said you're fine you just when
you get excited your heartbeat got
like to 140 something like that okay let
me ask you do you have any bringing your
ears any tinnitus or ringing ears you
don't kind of like
yes i have a bust in my ears yes okay
you have bugs in your ears okay
do you have do you have um any dizziness
or balance issues
no okay i have connecting in my knees
now
okay you have joint problems no no pain
just
i didn't say pain oh you have noise okay
you have noise okay
yeah so yeah when you have crunching
you might not have pain but you do have
stuff going on in there your cartilage
is going away
all right um and when you have this
heart issue is it
is it a regular beat or a fast rate or
what happens when you have the heart
issue
uh actually just uh like the heartbeat
goes fast when i get
excited like for example i used to solve
the sudoku thing
like when i start solving it i feel my
heartbeat goes up
okay yeah well my heartbeat used to go
up when i'd see pretty girls when i was
a teenager
okay so anyway yeah you have
osteoporosis
you have osteoporosis of the skull uh
which can be squeezing the tenth cranial
nerve which can cause this
sudden heart heart rate change okay it's
not a heart issue
it says osteoporosis the skull is
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve
the vagus nerve okay and then
um the tonight is ringing in the ears as
a squeezing of the auditory branch of
the eighth train on the nerve by
osteoporosis skull
you ever get any tingling or numbness or
pain in your fingers or wrists or
anything like that
no just cold sometimes it's called like
my hand my fingers okay
okay okay so here we go yeah you have
osteoporosis
including the skull i want you to get a
hold of that book it's all in your head
there's 25 different diseases you get
you've got like four or five of them
these 25 diseases because of
osteoporosis of the skull
but you have osteoporosis elsewhere
because your knees crunch and pop
so what you do is get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat broth i know
there's no sugar
i want you to excuse me i want you to um
take one healthy brain and heart pack
per month once you get another bottle of
selenium we have one bottle of saline in
the healthy brand heart pack but i want
you to get another bottle of selenium
not from walgreens
but ours with the five cofactors your
hair color will come back
because the hair color has nothing to do
with age it has to do with a nutritional
deficiency
okay which is going to kill you with a
ruptured aneurysm if you don't deal with
it
okay so once you get another bottle of
water slim so you can take three of
those twice a day
once you get um one bottle a month of
the msm so you can take three of those
twice a day and they will support and
promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the river rate bone makes
your bone itself including the bone
marrow cavity
and which is important now during this
pandemic so you can make antibodies and
white blood cells red blood cells and
platelets
and i want you to take our collagen our
glucogen get two bottles a month that's
you can take five of those capsules
twice a day
you can either take the pro joint fx at
noon time three of those or you can take
the collagen peptides at noon time
and for drinking okay we have great
coffee we have our
javalution coffees and we fertilize all
those
plants on the in the plantations where
we grow
in nicaragua we own the plantations we
put use our bloom and minerals so the
coffee has minerals in it
but we also have a water coming from
iceland you know what's going on in
iceland right now yeah the first
volcanic eruption they've had in 800
years there and we get our water
from the icelandic
water which has all these minerals from
underneath
the land because of these volcanic
eruptions well this is going to give us
a whole new supply of fresh minerals
okay so um i i make my
powdered drinks into liquid by putting
them into the icelandic water
which is one of our products and so
you're getting the extra minerals in the
water so we're really excited about that
so call us every every couple of weeks
because you're gonna have a great story
abba
you're gonna have a great story and um
yeah
you will help a lot of people with your
testimony so i look forward to hearing
in two weeks and four weeks and six
weeks please
thank you thank you so much you bet
awesome thank you abbas we appreciate
you
coming and joining us today now dr
wellick
i don't know how many emails and texts
that i get through the week i'm gonna
have to start
counting them but it's in regards to
the prostate having prostate issues well
you don't have to worry about that
i don't there's so many men out there
that do
and because i care about more than just
myself
dr wallach i want to know
what they why is prostate issues
such a problem i mean we've got elevated
psas
we've got cancer what can be done to one
prevent
for those who don't have prostate issues
yet okay yeah okay
okay okay well all tissue in the body
including the prostate and the ovaries
and
um testicles and you know all these
things
require 90 essential nutrients they all
have the ability to make new cells
repair themselves because you know
none of these cells live forever they
live for 30 days 60 days 90 days two
years whatever it is they die
you gotta be be replaced by other cells
one of the reasons why people get told
they have a prostate issue or they make
that
they surmise that themselves is that
they
have to urinate like every 10 minutes or
something like that oh my god my
prostate
thing is going crazy well they could
have a low back problem
and they're squeezing the nerves to go
to the prostate and so the prostate is
getting the signal
from the squeezed nerve saying p p p
because that nerve is being squeezed
just like when you get hammered toes
get burning and itching and all that
kind of weird stuff going on in your
feet and toes and ankles and legs
it's a back problem it's called sciatica
it's a peripheral neuropathy
so i'd probably say 90 of the time
the issues with the prostate gland are a
back problem
okay and then as long as they don't have
cancer
this is what i would suggest well let's
go for everything even if they have
cancer prostate cancer
that's been diagnosed by biopsy
they have to get rid of all the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat brown rhinos
no sugar you've never heard that before
but
you know everybody needs to do that
whether you have a prostate gland or not
then uh they need to get on one healthy
brain and heart pack per month per 100
pounds of body weight they need to take
the msm
one of those uh one bottle a month for
100 pounds of body weight three of those
twice a day they will support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae
well how does that help the prostate
well again if your discs are shrinking
your vertebrae getting close together
smashing those sciatic nerves
which some actually support the prostate
gland tell a prostate gland what to do
they get a squeeze
they tell a prostagland p p p kind of
stuff
and so or don't pee and then they have
to catheterize them
um put a permanent catheter in so
they're just dribbling urine all day
into a bag
and so that could be a back problem not
really a prostate problem
so that's why i do the bone and
cartilage and ligament thing
with that scenario and then if there's
no cancer there
i want to do two things number one they
need to take oh
they need to eat three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks not hard boiled that
won't work
but you have to appreciate the
testosterone like estrogen is 95
by weight cholesterol so they need three
eggs with soft yolks soft boiled soft
poached soft soft scrambled butter
twice a day and that's going to give
them the cholesterol to make
testosterone
also they need zero tests is there a
test
for the prostate um take three of those
twice as two bones a month
it's gonna give the sertoli cells in the
testicle what they need to make
testosterone along with the eggs
and the testosterone drives the prostate
function
and then we have what we call prostaff x
it has a bunch of herbs and
uh nutrients in there they're
specifically designed for prostate
health and support
and function and i take three of those
twice a day on prostitutes i take three
of those twice a day i'm 82 years old
and i don't have any problems in that
area whatsoever
okay and so um this is um
prostate responds very quickly when you
deal with all these issues
if you just take the prostate effect you
say well i took it for three months and
nothing happened what was the back
problem
okay so that's why i say do all this
stuff and you're gonna benefit all over
just like when you you know
you you had like 20 different problems
they're all gone because you dealt with
it
by doing everything i told you you
didn't just take one product
and so yeah you got to do the whole
recipe
to get the right cake well and i didn't
just do it for a couple days either dr
wallach
are you still doing it i'm still doing
it
how long have you been doing it now five
years now
all right congratulations five years
i've been doing for 73 years
yeah you've been doing a few a few more
years than mine 73 years yeah
i do have one question because you had
mentioned if they don't have
cancer they can take the zero test what
would you
add if cancer has been shown
in a biopsy okay uh i would add more
of our selenium i'd have to take three
selenium three times a day instead of
twice a day
okay if they have prostate cancer and i
would also take some of the other
products that support the immune system
again more fucoid z
uh take three of those minimum three
twice a day i do that
i take the ocean's gold three of those
twice a day
but i also take the cell shield rtq i
take three of those twice today
it supports the immune system and is
anti-inflammatory i also
take the um let's see here killer biotic
which deals with infections but also
deals with bad stuff going on
anti-inflammatory and so i take killer
biotic i take three of those twice a day
and i take the colloidal silver
colloidal silver
supports your immune system two droppers
full under the tongue
half hour before each meal two droppers
full under the tongue half hour before
bed
been doing that for 25 years it kills
all bad stuff
all right excellent excellent thank you
so much i mean
my email right now no joke dr wallach
has at least 200 questions in regards
wow
so that right there will be able to help
me answer
a lot of questions thank you so much
look forward to the next hand that it is
up and that
is rob rob go ahead and unmute yourself
hello you are on live with dr wallach
rob
hello thank you um i'm 67
white male 216 pounds
um i'm having pressure back in december
i was having
really high blood pressure i went and
saw my heart doctor took him three
months
to get me on the cath lab table my blood
pressure was
went into the emergency room 205 over
okay and this has been going on for a
couple of months they put me on the calf
table
in 10 minutes they said we already know
what your problem is but we can't fix it
you have a stent in your left corduroy
artery and it's 100 block i say well
then how
am i living they said your body created
a new pathway
for your blood to go to your body so
they put they said you only have two
options here take medicine or crack the
chest and do a bypass so i'm doing the
medicine
they got me on 10 milligrams of
amlifine am a-m-l-o-d-i-p-i-n-e
50 milligrams of hydrazine
h-y-d-r-a-l-a-z-i-n-e
a hundred milligrams of lor satin
50 milligrams of metropole
my blood pressure is now normal but
with medication i i am very big on
taking vitamins i take them every single
day i take multiple vitamins
you have any ideas vitamins vitamins
will not help you with your heart
problem
okay well i try to stay healthy so i'll
what can you tell me okay i can tell you
by looking at your hair
do you have varicose veins in your legs
no sir you have spider veins in your
legs
no sir in fact uh three years ago when i
went on social security i went to my
doctor
and i lost 30 i joined a weight a weight
loss
group called tops taking off pounds
centrally i lost 30 pounds the first
year
30 pounds the second year and um
so i started at 265 i got down to 190
i've gained some of my weight back
but um excuse me that's because you
haven't resolved your basic problem
okay okay um do you have any skin
problems any eczema dermatitis or
rosacea
no sir okay do you have any bowel
problems any constipation
diarrhea no sir but no sir but
six years ago i did have colon cancer i
had a tumor
and it did not get into my lymph lymph
nodes so i had it cut out and it's been
over five years and i'm cancer free
okay good congratulations um
yeah i'd be very interested to see um
the the the slides you know i want to
see the slides under the microscope
myself
because i don't know about the diagnosis
okay
um so anyway um what i want you to do
here
uh and you'll change because you'll see
your hair color will come back
i want you to get rid of all the bad
foods now you may have done some of this
but we got this
you know millions of listeners here so
they have to hear this too okay i need
you
i need to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat butter i know
no sugar
okay the only good oil is the oil you
put in your car no oils no olive oil no
extra extra extra virgin virgin virgin
olive oil that will give you cancer
okay okay then absolutely
i want you to at 216 pounds i want you
to take two healthy brain and heart
packs per month to full dose everything
twice a day
two healthy brain and hard pass per
month i want you to take uh two bottles
a month over
msm so you can take three of those with
each meal they're gonna support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself
which is important for the bone marrow
as well as the cartilage and the joints
and that kind of stuff
i also want you because of this block
coronary artery
i want you to take in the high blood
pressure i want you to even though
you're being medicated i want you to be
able to wean off the medication
okay like rebecca did i want you to
get on uh three bottles a month of our
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those uh twice
three three with each meal three with
each meal that's three bottles a month
of the ultimate daily classic
tablets and um it's going to support
healthy blood pressure
and also support healthy blood flow
through even blocked arteries now
you got to you got to do the diet also
as we just said
now what i want you to do is appreciate
you're not going to cold turkey off of
your
blood pressure medication what you're
going to do is you know take your blood
pressure on a regular basis and as you
see your blood pressure kind of coming
down a little bit
you can begin to come
decrease your blood pressure medication
based on the numbers just don't
well i'm starting wallex thing i'll just
dump all my
drugs don't do that okay and then
i also want you to take our uh z radical
capsules i want you to take three of
those
uh three three times a day is three
breakfast real estate dinner time
a z radical that's our nine algaes
and seaweeds capsules
and to give you weird trace minerals for
your bone marrow it's going to help you
with defending yourself and of course
um at your age 67 years old with havoc
pressure and all this other stuff going
on
um this means that um you're
at risk of having a very bad outcome if
you get the covet so you really want to
watch that whether you're vaccinated or
not
doesn't matter okay so give us a call
every couple of weeks give us an update
if nothing's happening tell us nothing's
happening but if you say you know
i'm not sure but you know my blood
pressure may have dropped a couple of
points here
and now i'm going to want you to turn
your head for me every time you come on
so i can see yeah
i can see your hair color okay and i can
see it in your beard your mustache and
all kind of stuff
okay so thank you rob we look forward to
hearing from you soon
thank you sir awesome thank you so much
rob and everybody i apologize i went
right through our break we were just
on a roll so dr wallach let's take a
five minute break
michelle's window you don't have
a microphone uh that we can see so if
you can turn your microphone on so that
we can
talk to you when we come back from the
break that would be super awesome
thank you yes thank you ruth ellen
so if you aren't able to find that
microphone if you click on the
microphone
it'll give you the option to use device
audio you want to make sure you click on
that
thank you
all right thank you and welcome back
everybody to ask
doc live just a reminder that this
program is brought to you by
askdoclive.com as a resource
for alternative options to
addressing health keeping healthy
and also addressing health concerns
get with the person that invited you to
this program
if nobody invited you to this program
then please feel free to go to our
website
we have a store there that offers all of
the products that dr wallach is
mentioning we also have
a contact us that if you have specific
health
concerns and you want to know what's
going to be best for you
you can send us an email we have a team
of certified holistic health coaches
standing by to help
you get on the right track and a better
journey to health
we also have a call team that is on
standby at eight
five five nine four
nine seven two three four
they are here to help anyone who has
never spoken to
anybody that's involved with youngevity
before
and have never tried the product so
they're here to answer some questions
for you
too now dr wallach are you
ready to get started again
i saw you here where'd you go
there you are yeah the mute thing popped
on so i had to mute myself
yes yes well you know they hear the the
walking across the floor and everything
going on
we want to try to eliminate that
sometimes during break thank you
you're welcome so let's go to our next
hand up dr
wallach michelle
michelle is busy at work but taking time
to join
us to ask her questions dr wallach so
michelle go ahead you are on live with
dr wallach
hi
oh okay so
we can't hear you the microphone is
connected but the volume on it on your
side might be down
so look into that and we'll go to the
next hand
and that is john john go ahead and
unmute yourself
you are online with dr wallach hi can
you hear me yes yes
we can hi doc so yes sir
i was on with you about three weeks ago
and uh i'm i just got all my supplements
i'm in canada and things were a bit slow
getting here so i just got my
the last of it uh yes on wednesday so
i'm starting the program
uh i've been following uh staying gluten
off all the gluten products for probably
six weeks now
so my first question is about
the vaccine the covet vaccine
do you recommend getting it okay
here's the deal stop there with that
question yep um
uh everybody's got to make their own
decision whether or not they're going to
get the vaccine or not
if you're going to get the vaccine you
want it to work right you know if you
want to maximize the benefit of vaccine
you got to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no gluten so we brought our anodes
so that you can maximize absorption of
the nutrients necessary for your body to
respond
vaccines do not kill viruses bacteria
fungus or yeast
vaccines only alerts your body to the
bad dna and
rna in the bugs so when the bug appears
your body says uh oh here's a bad guy
we've been alerted to this
and so your bone marrow is supposed to
release white blood cells t
lymphocytes that kind of thing
antibodies red blood cells platelets go
kill and eat the virus
okay now you're responsible for two
things in addition to
getting the vaccination if you're going
to get the vaccination vaccination in
itself
will not work that's why people say well
you know my mom had you know the two
vaccine thing
and uh three months later she died of
the covet how'd that happen she had her
two vaccinations well
what she eat for breakfast every morning
well she had oatmeal for breakfast every
morning for 70 years well that's why she
died
okay because her intestines were dead
those villian her intestines went away
and even if she was supplementing she
couldn't absorb the nutrients but if
she's eating gluten
and not supplementing her intestines are
dead the nutrients necessary for the
bone marrow to respond to the vaccine
never got there so there's these three
pieces you got to be able to absorb you
got to get the nutrition
in you through the intestinal wall to
the bone marrow
and then your bone brows got to be
making all the defensive systems to
respond to the vaccine
everybody says oh i've got the vaccine
i'm good to go i can do whatever you
want
no that's just like ten percent of it
the vaccine is just ten percent of it
i hope that answers the question uh yes
now
uh it's not here yet but it sounds like
we may be required to
to get the vaccine whether we want to or
not because
i know some people that their workplace
won't allow them to go
so well then you have a choice you
cannot get the vaccine lose your job or
get the vaccine keep your job i mean
that's your choice
that's correct so if let's just say i
decided i wanted to get it
you do you believe one is better than
the other because
some are mrna some are not mrna
well we'll find out we'll find out in 10
years which
which is better but they've all been
okay created
using um previously agreed upon
technology
right okay none of these are
experimental
okay so i'll go on to my other questions
so i'm just starting the program i would
sort of like to get a
a blood test sort sorted to as a marker
where i am right now does that make
sense to you to go and do that
okay i don't mind you getting a blood
test but a blood test is is only good
for three tenths of a millisecond
what happens 30 seconds later is totally
different right
okay because the blood is something
that's
changing every second okay so i want you
to get a hair analysis
okay you know from the nape of your neck
um
you can get the book a rare urban cures
go to chapter nine and ten tells you how
to collect the hair
how to package it up where to ship it
don't forget to put the check in with it
because it won't run the test without
the check
and you'll get two charts one chart is
going to go through all the essential
minerals and you'll get a graph with all
these bars showing you where they're at
are they
low are they in the middle where they
should be or are they some too high
and there's all kinds of scenarios and
we can talk about we don't have time
right now
yeah then also there's a second chart
which goes into the toxic metals lead
things like lead mercury uranium and all
these other weird
um toxic minerals that come from
factories and sprays and all kinds of
stuff like that
and so i do one of those hair analysis
once a year just for
to mark what's going on what's changed
in the last year so i've been doing that
gosh for 20 years
uh blood samples are not excuse me not
blood samples hair analyses
once a year and so uh i have a pretty
good idea
i've been gluten free for 73 years i've
been taking 90 cents of nutrients for 73
years
so i'm 82 years old now in pretty good
shape i don't have any of the
pre-existing conditions i have none of
them no blood pressure
issues no diabetes no arthritis no
irritable bowel syndrome
no thyroid issues no heart issues no
lung issues
i don't have any of that stuff okay
because i've been doing all the right
things for 73 years
right okay so um
so i in general i'm i weigh 216.
um i i've i'm 63 years old
uh we've determined i've got
australopirosis of the skull
uh and that um i have a
uh erectile dysfunction so you gave me
all my supplements to take
but there's some a few other things that
are going on in my body
one of them is i get athlete's foot
occasionally and right now i have jock
itch
uh so my doctors told me to take a a
topical cream but it doesn't seem to be
doing
the job okay okay so here's what i want
you to do
are you taking your two healthy brain
heart i just right
yes okay okay yeah because again we need
to give stuff to your bone marrow
because your bone marrow has got to
participate in all this with the white
blood cells to go kill
your jock itch bugs and your athlete's
foot bugs
okay it comes for your bone marrow so
it's also there's nothing topical that
can be done
well yes or colloidal silver yeah okay
there's no alcohol in it it won't burn
but you can put in you can put in baby's
eyes you know it's
oh it doesn't burn and so but it will
kill every kind of bug you can think of
viruses fungus yeast bacteria even
properly okay
yeah and and so i take i take orally
two um two um droppers full
30 minutes for each meal and two
droppers full 30 minutes before bedtime
been doing that for 25 years
okay that's that's one of the reasons
why i don't get infectious is i don't
get the flu and the colds and
because you know i have radio 24 7
for for 30 years so i can't afford to be
sick so i've been sticking with my
colloidal silver okay so i have a bottle
of that so
i i am taking it uh internally but
you're saying i can use it topically
also
yeah you can put on you know put it on a
cotton ball and
put it between your toes where you have
the um
athlete's foot and it'll kill the bugs
but also
by getting rid of the bad stuff and
taking your immune you know your
vitamins and minerals your bone marrow
is going to send
the white blood cells internally to kill
the athlete's foot bugs and jock itch
bugs also
okay all right uh and what will
i will the um is
i guess it's fungus right athlete's foot
and jock itch
will it uh sweet light shoes and will
you get it back
in the future well these things
live in the environment there's
thousands of bugs that live around you
all the time
okay okay and they're there and they'll
jump on you if they find a weak spot
and so it's your job to not let there be
weak spots okay
i'll let somebody else get on i thank
you very much for your okay
well thank you but yeah let's hear from
on a regular basis because your story
will help a lot of people thank you sir
awesome great thank you so much for
those questions john
thank you very much let's go ahead and
try michelle
again michelle go ahead and try unmuting
yourself let's see if your microphone
got connected
nope i don't see that it's connected yet
yeah i don't hear any any sound
i see her lips moving i see her lips
moving but she i don't hear the noise
because i take your question we'll get
your question answered
thanks rebecca and good morning dr
wallach good morning how can we help you
sir good hearing from you
um so i had a two-part question um one
on behalf of my wife who's 19 weeks
pregnant um
the other is for my aunt who was just
was just diagnosed with afib and also
tachycardia fluctuating in slash low
blood pressure
um okay i'm here i'm hearing music or
something in the background
oh so sorry about that one sorry about
that one second
there you go that's better thank you all
right okay
well okay first of all your wife is uh
nine weeks pregnant you said
uh yes she's 30 years old 165 pounds
five eight
okay now was she taking vitamins and
minerals before she got pregnant
yes she was okay good okay now
does she have any clinical symptoms
she's worried about or does she just
want to know
oh well well um she's been on the
healthy brain and heart back and
everything's fine but in the last two
weeks she's been getting migraines so i
wanted to ask you
about preventing migraines during
pregnancy
okay well migraines can be due to
osteoporosis of the skull
okay so make sure at 168 pounds she
needs to be taking two healthy brain and
heart packs from one she's
not only eating for two but she's eating
and supplementing for two right
so she needs two healthy brain heart
packs for a month is she gonna
breastfeed this baby or
yes yes okay good yeah so she needs two
healthy brain heart packs per month
i'll photos everything twice a day and
then
um i want her also to take the vitamin
d3 she can take three of those twice a
day particularly up in canada
right here in canada is that correct uh
no i'm actually in texas austin texas
okay austin texas okay yeah so she'll
she still needs three of those um
vitamin d3
capsules twice a day and she needs to
continue taking those
and um because when you have these sort
of things it's usually due
to either a vascular problem or a bone
problem
the vascular problem and she's how many
weeks pregnant now nine weeks pregnant
yeah she's 19 weeks 19 weeks oh okay
okay so okay so she's passed
the first trimester yes yes okay
so yeah so she can also uh take the
fucoid z
she can take three of those twice a day
that's anti-inflammatory
plus it gives her some weird trace
minerals that support the bone marrow
and all that kind of stuff
it wouldn't hurt for her also to get two
bowels amount to the ultimate daily
classic tablets
ultimate daily classic tablets and take
her take two with each meal
so there's not a big spike twice a day
she can have two of each meal
that's six a day two bottles of the
ultimate daily classic tablets that's
going to support healthy blood flow
through even blocked arteries in the
brain
um the uterus and every place else
okay and if she's on the tangy tangerine
already would you add that
yeah well there's just two totally
different issues here one is for
getting more blood supply to the brain
okay
and the kidneys blood supply to the
brain and the kidneys and
the other one is just a great
multivitamin mineral supplement that
covers all bases
and so when you have a clinical thing
going on that means for some reason
there's something missing someplace okay
so you gotta
add something which we call a secret
sauce
from from the side okay and then
i'll see here um
the second one was the afib who's that
your answer uh yes
my auntie so she is 55 years old 160
pounds
and also five eight and um she was just
diagnosed with afib and also
tachycardia if i'm saying that right
yeah tacky yeah
tachycardia yeah yeah tachycardia means
fast afib means your heart rate is going
fast fast and so slow
really weird okay this is all caused by
osteoporosis
for the skull squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve okay
so she's getting all the bad stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens and wheat bread rhinos no
sugar
then i wanted to have two healthy brain
and heart packs for a month two healthy
brain hard pack for a month to full dose
everything twice a day i also wanted to
get two bottles a month of our msm so
you take three with each meal
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between vertebrae bone rich bone itself
including the skull
okay and um afib is not a heart problem
it's a symptom it's you ever heard of
peripheral neuropathies
yes you ever heard of sciatica yes
okay what causes the pain and numbness
and burning in the feet and hammer toes
and all that kind of stuff
is it going on it's yeah it's a
peripheral neuropathy it's your back
okay it's the squeezing of the sciatic
nerves in the back so if you just treat
you know put something on your feet to
stop the pain is it helping really
okay no well the same thing here they
want to anesthetize her
open up her chest and do an ablation is
what they treat
um afib with in humans and they kill
more people than they help okay by
trying to kill the heart muscle
okay and so really let's treat her
osteoporosis of the skull
and the afib just goes away okay
um and then one follow-up um in terms of
taking a calcium supplement i was
wondering is there a calcium supplement
you would recommend other than
the osteo effects just without sugar
or um well i think most of them have
some kind of sweetener in them because
calcium tends to be dry and you know not
too
appetizing but myself i use cal toddy
because it has the mineral the minerals
in it as well
cal toddy and so i use the cal toddy and
i put
a tablespoon a half ounce of that in my
liquid drinks
you know in the morning for my btt 2.0
also
in the evening i take another tablespoon
in my liquid
of the of the cal toddy and that way
um i get more calcium and you know i
don't have osteoporosis of the skull
even though i'm 82 years old
and it wouldn't hurt for her to get a
couple of these books
um it's all in her head one for herself
and one for her doctor yeah i already
have it written down
okay and if she and if she um is in the
young duty business or you're in the
young jimmy business the cost of that
book will be tax deductible
as as a um something as you're doing to
build your business okay that sounds
great
okay all right thanks so much okay thank
you thank you sir
bye-bye all right awesome and
congratulations again jesse
so i just want to do a real quick recap
dr wallach and i was going to do it
earlier but i think this is a more
appropriate time
okay so we're looking at things that are
spine related you've got your discs that
are compressing
and all of these things like optic nerve
atrophy
migraines eye issues
prostate issues prostate issues
sciatic you know
yep it's like all of these things dr
wallacher because
we're decompressing the body's not
getting the nutrients that it needs to
stay
active and get keep those discs where
they're supposed to be
so it's so important folks that we need
to not
ignore these symptoms
because it's like you get one symptom
and another one and another one another
one and
the simple thing is it's all related to
the same thing
that's correct and of course when you
look at the people who live the longest
up in the hunza uh valley okay
um between pakistan and china your
average lifespan is 165 their oldest one
documented
actually agreed upon nobody doubts it
i was 265 years of age
okay dr lee chen yuan okay he's kind of
in modern times you know in the bible
people would be 800 years of age
700 days 969 methuselah
okay and these people all lived in the
middle east
and where these people lived the longest
okay
and that's because and even then they
were using wood ashes
which had minerals in it into their
garden and putting wood ashes in their
stew and their soup and
that kind of stuff as a source of
minerals
and when we went to electricity we gave
up the wood ashes
and doctors said don't waste your money
on violence meals just eat while you get
everything you need
and so nobody replaced the wood ashes
when it went away
when we went to electricity and so
even though you think you're using
grandma's famous recipe for her stew
you're not getting the same recipe she
had because she's putting wood ashes in
yeah there was wood ash going into a lot
of things other than just
physically putting wood ash all those
vegetables grown in
rich rich soil do you remember dr
wallach's 30 years well it wasn't 30
years ago but when i was
30 and going through the different
people in the bible
and how old they were i was at that
state where
i am so thankful we don't live that long
because
i hurt you that and now i'm looking
forward to 120.
so well well that's minimum
120 is minimum okay when i hit 120 you
you've got to be around doc yeah okay
well i will be
i'll be i'll be 150 i'll be 150 when
you're 120.
awesome awesome all right next let's go
to
jolin jolin has a great question go
ahead and unmute yourself jolynn
gotcha got it you're on live with dr
wallach
hi hi i'm so happy to meet you after all
these years okay
thank you thank you for calling at first
i
i talked to you about i had uh
neuropathy from chemotherapy
uh it's getting a little better but i
did get on your 90 essentials
glucosamine msm
and d3 i noticed a difference the first
week it was a unbelievable so
now my problem is though living in
certain areas i
suffer from barometric pressure
headaches
i did this when i was a kid it's uh when
i lived in the
desert for 30 years never had it
it's all related to environment
of whatever happens when you live up in
denver now
no no i'm in riverside california which
has
air in the world yeah and uh
it comes on right before a storm is
going to happen it's some kind of an
electrical thing that happens
like i said i had it when i was a kid
and i i
you know my mother says why are you
dressing so warm tomorrow because i
always put my
clothes out the night before school and
i said well it's going to rain she says
well how do you know that i said because
i have a headache
that stayed with me all my life until i
was in the desert
never had it is there anything we can do
for that
yes okay well first of all do you have
varicose veins in your legs or spider
veins in your legs
yeah one or two uh-huh okay now the
reason i know that is you have white
hair
yeah that's not dude it's not due to age
how old were you when you started
getting white here
about 45.
a hairdresser for many many years and uh
i also told my customers take vitamins
and your hair color come back
it does to a point it doesn't come
exactly back to what you have
well there's specific nutrients you need
to take okay
there's very specific nutrients that
that are involved in hair color
and the elastic fibers in the walls of
veins and arteries and skin
and that kind of stuff okay so so i want
you how much do you weigh jolene
132 right now okay what's your age
73 all right all right
any other issues have a pressure
diabetes no
no okay the opposite low blood pressure
okay do you have anything going on with
um
anything like fatty liver no i do
i do the hold the clark's a gallbladder
liver flush
unbelievable what comes out in the colon
i could not believe it
okay i had a colonoscopy let me tell you
the doctor
said he said i have never seen such a
clean
colon as you at any age and he said it's
all
pink and i thought wow dr wallace got to
hear this
thank you for the feedback okay now
um also uh do you have anything going on
with your skin any eczema dermatitis
psoriasis or rosacea
no i've always had acne blackheads over
active oil glands
when i was younger and i have scars from
all that
okay what about any tinnitus any ringing
in the ears or balance problems
uh i vertigo i have suffered from i've
been in the hospital because of that
okay um have you lost your sense of
smell or taste
no that's very good are you slowly
losing your vision where you need to
change your eyeglasses prescription
regularly
uh no because i just had a check and he
said you know your prescription
is better you're now than the last
prescription
in other words your eyes are getting
better good
okay good yeah excellent
okay so um you ever get hiccups
uh not not often no okay all right
so here we go once you get rid of all
the bad foods and again this is for the
rest of our listeners also right so
no no bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens and
wheat bread right now so sugar
and then at 132 pounds i want you to
have one healthy brain and heart pack
per month get another bottle of arsenic
not walgreens laying but
it's got the five cofactors in it one of
those cofactors is what's missing
causing you to have the white hair okay
and i get nervous about that because
people die of ruptured aneurysms when
they have white hair and varicose veins
and all that kind of stuff
so once you get another bottle of art
selenium not walgreens slim marsulinum
so you can take three twice a day one
bottle comes with the healthy branded
heart pack
i want you to get one bottle of our msm
so you can take three of those twice a
day
i'm doing that okay good i want you to
take three of our
vitamin d3 capsules twice a day there's
two bottles a month
i want you to take our glucogen take
three or four or five of those twice a
day but i also
want you to throw in in the middle of
the day either pro joint fx3 those
are our collagen peptides in the middle
of the day
a dose of that's a powder one scoop in
your drink or
apple sauce or something the first one
you said
is pro joint fx joint pro pro
pro joint fx okay pro joint fx
fx okay yep okay then
um i also want you to take our fucoid z
which is going to support your bone
marrow
it's your age you're at that point now
if you get hit with the
bug with a pandemic virus if
everything's not perfect you know
your age you have these pre-existing
conditions including age
uh your bone marrow isn't perfect and so
i want your bone marrow perfect so i
want you to get the
two bottles a month of the fucoid c
capsules you can take three of those
twice a day if you prefer the liquid you
can get a quart
per month of the z radical same thing
just tastes good kids like it
you can take a tablespoon which is a
half ounce twice a day of the
z radical are three of the capsules
twice a day there's two bottles a month
of the capsules
i travel a lot so i take the capsules
because they can't take the quartz
they're too heavy
on the airplanes and stuff like that
yeah okay so there you go and so that's
where i would go with this
and um i want to do a hair analysis what
book was that in
rare earth forbidden cures rare earth
and forbidden cure
that's correct okay and yeah do they i'd
like to know what your hair analysis
says
okay and then you know and then don't
forget you know our colloidal silvers
and i want to get on that i'm doing a
very high uh
3 000 a day vitamin c a good good brand
but i'd rather go that way
if that's even better okay well vitamin
c supports your immune system
this kills the bug with a shot to the
head okay this
kills the bug it's totally different
than vitamin c
so you can do both i do both i take you
know our chewable vitamin c i take two
of those
a day two of those a day one with
breakfast one with dinner time but i
also take and take my colloidal silver
four times a day uh two droppers full
under the tongue
half hour before each meal and two
droppers full under the tongue half hour
before bed been doing that for 25 years
okay all right well thank you julian
well
about the parametric pressure do you
think all this would help that
also or yes oh yeah yeah you're going to
see benefit there
absolutely that's that was my main
concern thank you today
today i don't remember because we've
been going back and forth here and all
over the place
yeah you say ultimate daily uh classic
tablets
yeah three of those twice a day ultimate
daily classic tablets through those
twice a day
they will support healthy blood pressure
and healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries
your eyes your brain your heart
your legs every place your kidneys okay
okay thank you so much
okay bye-bye bye-bye all right awesome
jolene thank you for
coming on with us and just a reminder
all the products that dr wallach is
mentioning today
are found at askdoclive.com in our store
and dr wallach here also taking the
beyond tangy tangerine
every day oh yeah great dose of vitamin
c
so we don't want to forget that vitamin
as well i have a question here from
jennifer dr wallach
her son has a s d
add hd and is heterozinus for
mthfr okay there's there's too many
abbreviations here deficit hyperactivity
disorder
okay and asd if i remember right is
on autistic spectrum
i might be wrong okay how old is this
kid
um does not
it does not say is he three fifteen
spectrum disorder
we'll see if she comes on
okay okay well yeah this is okay
go ahead with the mthfr
um with it being a mutated gene
they have a hard time with
um processing like folate
and b12 unless it's methylated
now have you ever heard of the science
have you ever heard the science of
crapola
well they have i have
but but i know that we have a methylated
version of the btt
and i know people that weren't able to
take the 2.0 can take the 2.5
without having any type of reactions
yeah well that's why we came out with it
yeah so i'm really excited about having
that because
so many people i'm just i'm amazed
at you know how people come out of the
woodwork
with all these different things and then
the product comes out
and we're just right there making
things available for everybody i love
okay
well thank you i appreciate that
compliment thank you rebecca now you
have to appreciate
that uh all the whole american longevity
which became
youngevity uh started when i was nine
years old
um i had um autism
uh anxiety violence behavior all this
kind of stuff when i was four years old
over a period of five years between age
four and nine my mom and dad took me to
20 different doctors so the
last one when i was nine was a little
grandmotherly type grandma pediatrician
by the name of mary jane skeffington
from st
louis and she took one look at me and
looked at the record and said look we're
going to have to institutionalize him i
said what does that mean mom she said
well they're going to put you in the
hospital
well how long am i going there she said
well maybe for the rest of your life
because 20 different doctors can't
figure out what you got they never heard
of it before
never seen it before and you're going to
kill yourself or kill somebody else or
you know you're tripping people and
pushing them down and stomping on their
face and all this kind of stuff
so you can't be doing that you're going
to institutionalize it rather than go to
jail
so that night when everybody else was
asleep i'm thinking i don't want to go
to an
institution for the rest of my life i'm
saying okay
i'm eating what everybody else is eating
but
why am i having all this problem i'm
saying our animals in the garden you
know they're eating
we're going to kill them and eat them in
a couple of months and they're eating
everything we're eating out of the
garden now wait a minute wait a minute
we're giving them alfalfa pellets with
all these vitamins and minerals in it so
the next morning i threw my cheerios out
to the chickens
they ran up and chomped down on those
cheerios
and i put the alfalfa pellets all the
vitamins minerals in my cereal put milk
with it and that's what i had for
breakfast from then on
was these alfalfa pellets about minerals
well in three days time after five years
of getting worse and worse worse 20
doctors couldn't figure it out
i was cured just three days
well that told me that they didn't know
what they were talking about okay that
who are these people call themselves
doctors
i'm only nine years old so i began to
and going to church i never said
anything to anybody and after a couple
weeks people were whispering and
pointing to me because i wasn't
disrupting the services i'm singing
within the hymnal
and all this kind of stuff and i'm just
a regular member of the church at that
point
and i'm only nine years old and so
finally after a couple of months this
little lady came up to me and this was
the bottom line she says
i hear you can cure my diabetes i said
ma'am i'm only nine years old i don't
even know what diabetes is
so i went back home and i looked in the
reference books because you live on the
farm you don't get the doctors all the
time so you have little reference books
for animal diseases and for human
diseases and so i looked at them both
and it turns out the diabetes is a
simple nutritional deficiency disease
one genetic and so you didn't need to
take all these injectable
things for diabetes so i looked it up
and began you know and i started every
time anybody asked me a question i'll
look it up i'll have an answer tomorrow
kind of thing and so i began to put
products together and whatnot
but that's why when i graduated in high
school in 1958 and went to agriculture
school
i got my degree in agriculture got my
degree in veterinary medicine got my
degree in pathology
got my degree as a naturopathic
physician and
i treat people all over the world i see
2 million patients a day now all over
the world through your eyes and other
people's eyes
and they feed me back and so we have a
tremendous amount of information
and of course you've got the website to
get my books and cds and dvds
i urge people to get them because they
will add 25 years to your life
they will 25 to 50 years for life i will
pay the shipping if you get on auto ship
for the products
and you can help your family you can
help your neighbors you can help your
workmates
and your youngevity business whether
you're a customer or an associate a
business builder
either one you get you get a um
uh it's
you you're getting the whole sale prices
i will pay the shipping if you get an
auto ship and if you sign up as an
associate first time and also when you
renew every year
i will give you each time 500 bucks free
500 bucks free worth of business
building materials and information
plus a new free website
that it's incredible dr wallach i mean
i've tried other businesses before
and i had to pay a monthly fee for my
website just to have it
and here fifty dollars for the year i
mean that works out to less than four
dollars
four dollars a month for my website and
it's
all of the stuff that comes with it
youngevity handles
the inventory they handle the products
that are they're available
they maintain the website they do the
accounting they can't they
cut the checks all i have to do is
market and share my story please share
tax deductions based on how much square
footage in your house you use
for your young store my new computer i
write off my phone i write off
my internet i write off you can you can
do you write off part of your mortgage
or your rent
based on the square footage of the floor
space you and your young dividing
business is a willable asset you can
leave it to your church your kids your
family
your dog whoever you want to leave it to
yeah absolutely
and my skin care my hair products
my my clothes i mean all of that
i'm able to write off oh
it's it's fabulous i love it love it
love it
now i we've got um let's try to get at
least one more hand and then i have
one more uh message that's come in um
this past week
so monica is 56 and a half years old
she's 125 pounds
she has a brain tumor she has seizures
anemia allergies menopause with hot
flashes
sweats she had a partial hysterectomy
and 18 months ago she was put on
kidney dialysis and they're telling her
it's because she has high blood pressure
dr wallach this is a beautiful beautiful
lady just
the sweetest kindest heart very giving
and 125 pounds she's 56 years old right
right okay she's got osteoporosis
okay uh she's got some blockages in her
arteries which is causing the kidney
issues
uh and blood pressure issues um
and then she got seizures uh she's got
stuff going on her brain obviously so
here we go
125 pounds 128 pounds whatever it is
i wanted her to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat brother i
know so sugar
125 pounds i wanted to get one healthy
brain and heart packed per month and
wanted to get another bottle of our
selenium arsenic not walgreens lamb
we need the co-factors i want to take
three of our slime at breakfast and
through the dinner time
i also want her to get her ultimate
daily classic tablet she can get two
vowels a month of that so i can take
three twice a day
i want her to get our zera femme zera
xerifem
so she can take three of those twice a
day she needs two ballasts a month
the xerifem that'll support uh the
um making of estrogen even removed all
over portion of her
ovaries uh there's other portions of her
body and uh that actually makes some
estrogen also to help her with some of
that stuff
um then i also want her to take
our fucoid z i want her to take three of
those twice today
um that algae and seaweed has these
trace minerals in it to support the
immune system
okay but also or anti-inflammatory and
then i
also want her to eat three eggs twice a
day with soft yolks hard-boiled eggs
won't count fried eggs don't count in
fact they cause cancer
uh soft balls soft poached soft soft
scrambling butter
twice a day three of them i also want
her to take
our let's see here
i think i said ultimate daily classic
tablets three twice a day
a few quiet z okay that that's a lot
let's start going there
uh that covers everything uh that she
complained about
um yeah i think
not at all doc that covers it all okay
and so let's hear from her every couple
of weeks any time she goes to the doctor
and gets
a you know kind of an examination what
the doctor says
and her story is going to help a lot of
people because
this is middle-aged people getting five
six eight
ten different diseases they go to three
different specialists they're on all
these medications that's their whole
life is running around between doctors
and going to the pharmacy and everything
it's all nutritional deficiencies right
now dr whiley because she's on dialysis
she's on binders
of the yin yang phosphorus binders
potassium binders
let's get her started on this and then
in a couple of weeks we'll be able to
kind of
adjust things and tell her we don't want
her to just cold turkey off enter her
medications okay
she's got she's got to see improvement
symptoms and then we can begin to reduce
their medications based on the numbers
now should there be a time difference
between
when she's taking those binders and when
she's taking her nutrients
well i want her to take her nutrients
with meals
and i don't know what the directions are
on the medications she's taking whether
she should take him you know in the
morning
at night or she's taking you know i
don't know
but she needs to take her supplements
with the meals
all right perfect thank you so much next
let's go to michelle who has her hand up
michelle
let's try one more time
yes i think we hear you
no not working still not hearing you she
gotta
bye michelle okay you say we got
something else here
no let's go to bill who has his hand up
bill go ahead and unmute yourself is
that me yeah
you are on the way with doctor wildville
yes uh
i'm 83 years old i'm 5 foot 10
about 178 pounds i had bypass
in 1975 at age 37 i had it
again in 1987 where they use the mammary
artery
um my prop main and i'm on medication
for
statins for my cholesterol and
metapropyl for blood pressure
uh and my main problem now
is that a problem with my bowels and
and constipation my blood sugar
has been borderline and
reading was high but good and i had
prostate cancer in
2000. other than that i'm in good shape
okay 93 years old did you say
no i feel that but i'm only 83. oh okay
all right so uh what i want you to do is
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens there are no gluten-free oats
uh the gluten in oats is called gliadin
no gluten
no sugar no wheat pryor oats and then
um at 178 pounds i want you to have two
healthy brain and heart patch per month
two healthy brainerd heart pattern month
to full roast everything twice a day
i want you to get three bottles a month
of our ultimate daily classic tablets
take three with breakfast readathons
through
dinner that'll support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries in your
heart your brain your kidneys
um and uh also support healthy blood
pressure
i also want you to take the
and see here uh the synaptive uh take
three of those twice a day uh that's
going to support uh the brain
function i want you to also take the
uh fucoid z i want you to take three of
those twice a day
uh that's going to support your bone
marrow so you can make
antibodies to protect you against the
bug you're 83 years old you're you know
once you're a senior senior like that
you're in trouble if you get the covet
thing so we don't want you to do that
with all these pre-existing conditions
you've had
and then the prostate thing i want you
to take our ultimate
let's see here let's go to let's go
another direction here
let's take the btt 2.0 tablets the btt
2.0 tablets they do not replace
they are not in exchange for the btt 2.0
powder which is vitamins minerals
the btt 2.0 tablets are an
anti-inflammatory
but also they support the immune system
i want you to take three of those twice
a day i do that just for prevention
but because you have a history of
prostate cancer i want you to do that
it will also help you quiet down the
arteries in your kidneys in your heart
and so on
and so um pre-diabetes
um i want you to take uh three of the uh
sweeties capsules twice a day there's
two bottles a month
and um you know you can get the test
strips for urine you can get the test
strips for you know prick your finger
with one of those little
blade things and get a drop of blood you
don't even need to be able to read they
color code
stuff on the label of these test strips
and they only cost about 50 each you
don't need to spend 100 bucks for
an office visit you don't need to spend
200 for the lab and you don't need to
sit there for a half hour
in the waiting room with everybody
coughing and and belching and burping
all over you with the covet
and so um everything you have here
is either directly or indirectly related
to a nutritional deficiency
and so by getting on the diet getting on
these supplements
and doing this faithfully all of these
things
have the power to go away
well thank you very much okay keep in
touch with us every couple of weeks
a lot of people have the same scenario
you have bill and they will appreciate
your story and your story
your testimony will help a lot of people
well thank you very much doc
okay okay god bless you bill thank you
you too
thank you all right everybody i can't
believe
that two hours are up already
this is a stock live and again it has
been my
pleasure to be able to host this program
with dr while i can bring him to you
as you are looking for your journey
to optimal health and it it's possible
folks it's not
too late so dr wallach
yes thank you so much for being here
with us
okay well thank you rebecca thank you
john t and thank you and
your whole team you know you got no sema
you got ruth ellen
you got all these other people out there
thank you for the whole team
yes we have an amazing team and we will
be here every friday to bring this
program to you the past doc live program
again don't forget to get back with the
person that invited you to this program
we'll be here for the next 300 years
rebecca
300 let's go doc i'm ready
i'm ready i don't know if the world's
ready for us
we better hurry up and get busy right
we're
see we're like the marines we're the few
the proud the brave we're you know
everybody doesn't believe but they're
the ones who die early
that's right that's right so what we do
is we plant seeds
we water those seeds and eventually
the seeds die or they come to their
senses and start getting
knowledgeable about what they can do
that doesn't include chemicals
[Laughter]
thank you dear all right everybody
have a fabulous weekend and we will see
you
next friday again thank you to
my co-hosts ruth ellen and nasima and
jonty who makes this possible
and a replay he is fabulous about
getting those up on the askdoclive.com
website for you to be able to use and
enjoy
and share for everybody you know
take care everybody bye for now and
please go for it and have a better by
the minute live
we'll talk to you later okay bye